I've raised chickens now for about seven years
and this year we decided to do our first meat growth.
With the rising cost of meat
and us wanting to have a bit more food security,
we thought raising meat birds would be a good idea for us.
This week
we've been slowly processing them all and getting them in the freezer.
So let me show you how we do it.
It's pretty important that you have the right equipment.
You can buy this equipment or you can rent it,
or you can also make some of your own.
We decided to purchase ours
as we know we're gonna be doing some more ME bits in the future.
Is a kill cone. Is pretty important step.
This keeps the chicken really calm,
holds it nice and snug and keeps it still while you do the, um,
ending right here. I use garden snips
as it is the most quick and efficient way to get the job done.
And you will let the bird sit here and bleed out.
There is some movement still.
This is just the muscles and tendons still moving around.
We've heard of the saying the headless chicken
is because if you cut a chicken's head off,
it will still run around. It is dead,
but the body still has energy built up inside it.
Then I'm gonna dip the chickens in 150 degree water.
This removes the skin and feathers.
The heat in the water opens the Pores up on the skin
for the feathers to be easily removed.
We also put Dawn dish soap in here.
And this definitely gives the chicken a little clean
cause they are dirty. They got poop in their feet.
Um, so I like to do the step two.
And now we're gonna head over to the chicken plucker.
Now, we did purchase this plucker
as we plan on raising chickens for the year.
Um, you can rent yours.
Um, this didn't work as well as I thought it would.
The chicken thing sometimes gets stuck in the rubbers,
little rubber knobs. But it did the job.
I'm gonna give it a final rinse off
as I don't want any feathers or dirt on the chicken.
Then I'm gonna start the butchering process.
First off, I cut the feet.
I'm gonna save the feet for making broth.
I'm gonna get rid of the skin.
I don't want the skin in the broth.
I have a little bin to the side of me that has, um,
stuff I wanna save for broth.
And then the other bin has, um,
where I'm gonna put all the organs and giblets that I don't wanna keep.
The next step is I'm gonna cut open in the top,
underneath the neck here, and I'm gonna cut the crop out.
When a chicken eats,
it first goes down to the crop before it goes down to its intestines.
The crop kinda acts like its stomach.
Um, so I'm gonna slightly, uh, slowly.
Sorry. Pull this out with my hands.
Try not to use a knife, as I don't wanna nip into it.
And I'm gonna remove the esophagus, um, and the windpipe.
I'm gonna keep using my fingers,
as it is the best way to kind of remove the membranes.
Some membranes are tough. This one was a pretty easy one.
And then I'm gonna yank on that
and pull the intestine part up
into where it kind of just releases right there.
And I'm just gonna nip it off.
Now I'm gonna take the neck off,
and I'm gonna save this for chicken broth.
It's got lots of fat on it and that great bones for bone broth.
Then I remove the tail. Some people call this the Pope's nose.
Um, some people say to remove it,
some people say to leave it.
I did half and half, so I'll be able to tell if
in the future that I would like to remove it.
Then I'm gonna carefully cut into the bow area
and remove all the internal organs.
It's very important that you don't pierce open any of the bowel.
You don't want any bacteria, salmonella,
E. Coli or whatever to break into the meat.
Here's the part where I cut off the top there.
Um, that was the pipe
that was leading into that part of the chicken's intestines.
Now I'm pulling them all out.
I pulling out some kidneys.
Um, the liver's Right here.
And you gonna gently and firmly pull this off.
You can see this chicken had a lot of fat on it.
This chicken could have been butchered a few weeks ago.
We just had some time restraints.
Now I'm gonna slightly and carefully cut the butthole out,
and without nicking and cutting the intestines,
but I do want to keep some of that fat.
These chickens have a lot of fat around their buttholes.
Now that's complete, I can remove the lungs and the heart.
Hmm.
I'm just getting everything a little look over.
And just to show you guys, um,
what the organs look like inside,
this chicken definitely had some, um,
build up of fat on the organs.
It was time for it to be expired.
Um, but, yeah,
no disease. Um,
it was a pretty healthy chicken.
And I'm gonna package it in this plastic chicken bags,
and I'm gonna put it on ice.
And then later on, I will shrink wrap these and put them in the freezer.